[Music]
one of the cooler films this year was
Godzilla king of the monsters yeah
people are saying this movie sets up
what could be a remake of one of the
biggest monster movies of all time
King Kong vs. Godzilla now I love King
Kong and Godzilla and I thought wouldn't
it be it's just amazing if we could do
something at our comic-con shows with
these two massive monsters of course
here's the problem the Spreckels theater
that we're in now is 86 feet tall
King Kong is approximately 270 feet tall
Godzilla stands at almost 355 feet so
that was clearly not going to work but I
would not give up so after weeks weeks
of consulting with structural engineers
and the theater's fire marshal we've
finally found a great solution so ladies
and gentlemen who wants to see the
world's most badass Titans decimate the
city of San Diego right here on arts
dance
ladies and gentlemen witness the awesome
destructive power of King Corgi versus
Godzilla King Corgi is a cardigan Welch
the most fearsome of all breed of Corgi
Dogzilla stands nearly 18 inches tall
and he didn't nap today so he's really
pissed we have recreated a scale model
of San Diego and we are now going to set
them free where they will battle here
comes the Air Force
[Music]
[Applause]
there goes ping-pong game
they seem to be eating small treats on
the street
[Applause]
Hair Club some pranks driven by late to
defend the city again not too much
happening some buildings kind of being
[Applause]
and they're leaving and the mice on the
tanks are really doing nothing right now
and you can see why we didn't want to
put this on the air necessarily but we
just thought it why not give it a shot
ladies and gentlemen king turkey head
cogs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this this is the kind of stupidity
America it needs more of not less up
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]